and then I had a sheep run into me and I  face planted in mud full on mud and the  whole set had you know when we were  working outside we'd be shooting in  these tiny little Villages that uh  people would be coming and visiting and  like fans would be coming and waiting  just it's exciting there's a film set  and on this one day there was probably  like 50 to 60 people waiting on the side  of the barriers just like with their  iPhones like this and I had a very  simple scene where I had to just walk  across just walk across the road like  that just walk but with really intense  facial expressions going on and as I was  walking past the Sheep this sheep  wouldn't move out the way so I like  gently patted the bum and that sheep  went like and then another Sheep next to  it went like and then that sheep ran  into me and I flipped over the sheep and  went straight down into like cow pet it  was like in full-on mud it was great